After our warm-up, we can
now come to the real problem.
We have, again, a
random variable Theta
with a known prior distribution.
And we're interested
in a point estimate.
What will be
different this time,
however, is that we now
have an observation.
And we also have a model
of that observation
as a conditional
distribution given
the value of the true parameter.
We observe a value of
that random variable.
That value is little x.
And on the basis
of that value, we
would like to now
come up with a point
estimate of the unknown
random variable Theta.
How do we proceed?
We can, of course,
use the Bayes rule.
And the Bayes rule
is going to give us
a distribution for the
unknown random variable given
the observation that
we have obtained.
And that distribution could
be discrete or continuous.
Let me just plot something
as if it's continuous.
And now that we have the
posterior distribution
of Theta, we would like to
come up with a point estimate.
How do we do it?
Remember our earlier conclusion.
If we do not have
any observations,
if we live in a universe where
we have a distribution of Theta
and we want a point
estimate, the optimal,
the one that minimizes
the mean squared error,
is the expected value
of our random variable.
But now we live in a
different universe,
in a universe where we have
a conditional distribution
of Theta.
We want to minimize the
conditional mean squared error,
because this is the
mean squared error that
applies to this conditional
universe in which we have
obtained a particular
observation.
What is going to be the
result of this minimization?
Well, this is a problem that's
identical to the problem
of minimizing this quantity,
except that now this problem is
posed in a conditional universe.
So we just follow
the same steps.
And obtain the same
solution, the solution
is going to be
the expected value
of the unknown random
variable, except that now we
live in a conditional universe.
And therefore, we should take
the relevant expected value
which is the conditional
expectation given
the information that we
have available in our hands.
So to summarize, what we obtain
is that the optimal estimate
is the conditional expectation.
And this is a relation
between numbers.
But if we want to think about
it more abstractly, we have
designed an estimator which
is based on a random variable,
capital X, and calculate
the expected value
of our random variable that
we're trying to estimate,
namely Theta, on the basis of X.
Let us now continue
with some observations.
Remember that the
expected value of Theta
minimizes this quantity.
And we can write
this more explicitly
in terms of the
following inequality--
that if we use the expected
value as an estimate,
the resulting mean
squared error is less than
or equal to the
mean squared error
that we would have
obtained if we
had used any other estimate, c.
So this is a relation
that's true for all c.
Now, let us take this
inequality and translate it
into our more
interesting context where
we have an
observation available.
Once more, the
conditional expectation
minimizes the mean
squared error.
Let us write out
explicitly what this
means in a form analogous to
what we wrote down earlier.
What it means is that
the expected value
of Theta minus the
estimate, namely
the conditional
expectation, squared.
In this conditional
universe in which we live,
this is less than or equal
to the mean squared error
that we would have obtained if
we had used any other estimate
in the place of the
conditional expectation.
So for any value g of x
that we might have used,
the error would have
been at least as large.
Why am I using this
notation g here?
Let us go back to
the bigger picture.
What we have is that we are
obtaining a numerical value x.
We do some processing
to it which
corresponds to some function g.
And we come up with
an estimate which
is a function of the little
x that we have observed.
So no matter what
estimate we use,
the mean squared error is
going to be at least as large
as the mean squared
error that we obtain
if we use the
conditional expectation.
Now, let us take this
inequality here and write it
in a more abstract form.
Suppose that we have settled
on some particular estimator
and we want to compare this
estimator with the expected
value estimator.
Then we're going to get
the following inequality.
If we use the
conditional expectation
as an estimator in a
conditional universe
where we know the value
of the random variable X,
the corresponding
mean squared error
is going to be less than or
equal to the mean squared error
obtained by the
alternative estimator g.
What does this inequality say?
This inequality is simply
an abstract version
of the previous inequality.
The previous inequality
is true for all little x.
Here we have an inequality
between random variables.
This random variable
here is a random variable
that takes this specific
numerical value, whenever
capital X takes
the value little x.
When X takes the
value little x, we're
conditioning on this event.
And when X is equal to
little x, this quantity
takes on this particular
numerical value.
And similarly, on
the other side,
this is a random
variable that takes
this particular
numerical value whenever
capital X is equal to little x.
Now that we have an inequality
between random variables,
actually between
conditional expectations,
we can take expectations
of both sides.
And we use the law of
iterated expectations.
The expectation of a
conditional expectation
is an unconditional expectation.
So we obtain this
as the expected
value of this quantity.
And it's less than or
equal to the expected value
of this quantity
using, again, the law
of iterated expectations.
We obtain this relation here.
And what this
inequality is saying
is that the overall
mean squared error,
if we use the conditional
expectation, now
as an estimator, is less than or
equal to the mean squared error
that we would obtain if we
had used any other estimator.
So this inequality refers
to the following picture.
We obtain an observation
which is a random variable.
We process that random
variable to come up
with an estimator which is a
function of the random variable
that we observe and so is
itself a random variable.
So when we use this random
variable to estimate Theta,
we obtain a certain
mean squared error.
This is going to be at least as
large as the mean squared error
that we obtain if we use
the conditional expectation
as our estimator.
So to summarize, the
conditional expectation
of Theta, viewed as
a random variable,
as an estimator, what we call
the LMS estimator of Theta,
has the property
that it minimizes
the mean squared error over
all possible alternative
estimators.
So if you want to design this
box using some other function
g, you're going to obtain
a mean squared error that's
going to be no better than
what you obtain if you were
to use the conditional
expectation.